[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo et on va bien sûr parler de
l'italie après les élections à le pays
est plus que jamais fracturé en deux à
la lutte est ouverte entre extrême
droite et populiste un difficile de
savoir qui gouvernera le pays demain ni
la droite ni la gauche ne détient la
majorité c'est le populisme qui triompha
le mouvement 5 étoiles en tête 1
puisqu'il termine avec 32 et demi des
20% des voix mais aussi le parti
d'extrême droite la ligue 1 qui
recueille 10,7 et demi pour cent des
suffrages alors comment expliquer cette
vague populiste et quelles conséquences
pour l'europe c'est le thème de notre
débat aujourd'hui trois invités montjoie
sur ce plateau mercedes bresso
bonjour vous êtes députée européenne
italienne à du groupe des socialistes et
démocrates
vous êtes membre du parti démocrate et
le parti de matteo renzi un grand
perdant des élections merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation stelios loulou
bonjour vous êtes député européen grecs
1 du groupe de la gauche unitaire
européenne membre de syriza
il est aussi journaliste et réalisateur
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
enfin jean quatremer vous êtes
correspondant de libération à bruxelles
à je signale votre blog sur internet
coulisses de bruxelles a pour ne rien
rater de l'actualité européenne avant de
débattre les images c'est un pays
habitué depuis longtemps au désordre
politique n'est aujourd'hui d'italie est
vraiment en roue libre à aucun parti
aucune coalition n'a obtenu la majorité
pourtant une tendance se dégage un
l'hostilité à l'europe et le rejet des
élus françois moulin
deux scores historiques mais pas de
vainqueur ni matteo salvini
le patron de la ligue du nord ni luigi
di maio à la tête du mouvement 5 étoiles
n'ont réussi à remporter la majorité des
sièges au parlement
salvini le candidat d'extrême droite
alliée de marine le pen au parlement
européen emmène une grande coalition de
droite avec silvio berlusconi
ils recueillent ensemble 37% des
suffrages
c'est une grande satisfaction pour la
ligue pour salvini ces résultats sont
historiques n'avons jamais eu de tels
résultats dans le passé
nous recueillons des votes du nord au
sud je crois que matteo salvini a su
gagner ce défi
aucune alliance n'est envisagée avec le
mouvement cinq étoiles de luigi des
maillots l'autre grosse surprise de ces
élections qui devient avec 32% des
suffrages le premier parti d'italie
c'est côté d'aaa des garamantes r si ces
résultats devaient se confirmer ce
serait une apothéose et cela démontre le
travail que nous avons fait et surtout
cela démontre que tous devront venir
parler avec nous
le parti démocrate de matteo renzi lui
essuient une défaite historique avec
moins de 20% des voix
au pouvoir depuis 2013 le parti de
centre gauche va jouer les arbitres une
alliance avec les populistes du
mouvement 5 étoiles n'étant pour
l'instant pas exclu une situation
instable se dessinent les tractations
des prochains jours s'annoncent longues
et complexes
lors des dernières élections de 2013
elle avait mis plus de deux mois à
aboutir
[Musique]
mercedes bresso qui est bordé l'oas et
le titre du quotidien il tempo lundi
dernier ça résume assez bien la
situation
ouais ça résume plutôt bien la situation
je peux dire c'est certain que nous
avons perdu parce que nous avons perdu
énormément de voix ce qui n'est pas
certain si quelqu'un a gagné parce que
le système électoral les primes les
coalitions et donc la réalité ceux qui
ont gagné sur le centre droite avec
matteo salvini de vente donc ça c'est
quelque chose de pour l'europe la plus
inquiétante les cinque stylet qui nous
ont toujours cracher dessus maintenant
il essaye de relancer un peu de de
message mais je crois que notre devoir
c'est de faire l'opposition il ya
quelqu'un qui a deux deux groupes qui
disent avoir gagné bien le président de
la république a le choix un vu qu'il ya
deux gagnants c'est la première fois
qu'on a deux gagnants est en réalité
aucun c'est lorsque le groupe comment
vous réagissez au succès du populisme et
de l'extrême droite à qui totalisent
plus de 50 % en italie un des six pays
fondateurs
bon d'accord il ya la crise profonde du
système politique traditionnelle
italienne mais aussi je pense qu'il ya
des facteurs qui concerne aussi les
bruxelles les dirigeants européens
pasquet on a laissé tomber l'italie on a
laissé le taux bas l'italie à la fois ci
la question des réfugiés
comme ce fut le cas aussi avec la grèce
mais aussi on a laissé tomber les
gouvernements à enrayer les forces
démocratiques et progressistes en italie
la mode et de l'extrême-droite est
partout
les faits qui on a beaucoup de
difficulté de former un gouvernement
on est parti on les voit partout même en
allemagne
alors nous avons à mon avis c'est la
dernière
avertissements à l'europe qu'il faut
changer la déco radicalement delà de la
direction faisait de la politique jean
quatremer un certain rejet de l'europe
at il contribué à la montée de ce
populisme tous les cas ce que ce qui est
défait dans les urnes
année après année c'est la politique
européenne où la politique économique
telle qu'elle était vue par une partie
de la droite européenne et notamment la
cd ou allemandes ça faut dire les choses
clairement
c'est à dire quand même je dirais que
c'est le modèle de gouvernance de
wolfgang schauble l'arrogance et le côté
donneur de leçons vous faites comme si
fait comme ça nous sommes les meilleurs
et c'est qu' effectivement n'a pas
fonctionné et le refus de toute
solidarité aussi financière alors sa
passe était la grèce a été hélas à
laboratoire un peu malheureux mais je
veux dire que le côté allemand c'est on
veut bien vous aider mais vous allez
prendre une cure de rigueur absolument
vieux violente quelque chose qui a été
rejetée et les allemands brutalement
découvre la nécessité la de la
solidarité quand ils sont eux-mêmes
débordés par des réfugiés et à ce moment
là les allemands deux appels à l'aide
et c'est vrai que personne n'est venu à
en être des allemands pas plus qu'on est
venu à l'aide d'ailleurs des italiens
c'était chacun pour soi les français
n'ont pas été particulièrement brillant
dans cette affaire on a surtout on a
multiplié les contrôles aux frontières
renvoyer les enfants dans les montagnes
vers c'était à donner une image de
l'europe en fait non solidaire donneuse
de leçons mais encore une fois ce n'est
pas l'europe c'est les ce sont les
forces de droite qui domine l'europe si
on change pas l'europe le plus
rapidement possible la prochaine fois
dans nombreuses en trois ans quatre ans
cinq ans ça sera l'extrême droite
partout je partage à deux seulement
l'analyse que pour nous fédéraliste
européenne pour ceux qui sont pour
l'europe c'est urgent de changer
l'europe l'europe unie ne peut pas être
une europe qui ne fait que donner des
leçons c'est doit être c'est d'ailleurs
ce maquereau dit une europe tiède qui
protège parce qu'on n'est plus les plus
forts au monde 1 on a besoin aussi de se
protéger donc il faut offrir à nos
citoyens protection civile sur ce vote
protestataire en italie c'est quoi la
crise économique alors on y est je crois
je fera que l'italie n'est pas sorti de
la crise économique pour tout le monde
on est sorti dans le sens que on en a un
bon taux de croissance on a recommencé à
créer des emplois
mais ce n'est pas vrai pour tout le sud
au sud les jeans post elles n'ont pas
gagné ni contre l'europe unie pour la
droite ni même pas contre les migrants
ils ont gagné en promettant en salaires
pour tous sans travailler et ça c'est
c'est inimaginable c'est ce que nous on
a dit mme évidemment c'est plus
difficile à faire comprendre ce qu'il
faut c'est créer du travail
on ne peut pas imaginer un pays qui vit
aux crochets de qui de soi même que qui
va payer ces salaires un promesses
démagogiques dormait dans les magazines
et très démagogique
si vous regardez le nombre de chômeurs
dans les régions du sud vous voyez tout
de suite le vote cinq étoiles c'est
l'idée d'avoir de toute façon une
garantie 1an salaires
et puis travailler au noir quelque chose
que malheureusement on fait souvent dans
notre pays alors je crois que on ne peut
pas dire qu en europe en italie ont
gagné les européennes ont gagné les
populistes et ça c'est les 5 5 étoiles
et ceux qui sont contre les migrants
c'est vrai l'italie étaient laissés
seuls
mais c'est vrai aussi qu'on a un énorme
problème en europe par tous les partis
de gauche peur de devoir parce que ils
font leurs devoirs de l'aide humanitaire
et isaac cette incitation
contre laquelle on a beaucoup de
difficulté à l'it et je crois que
l'italie a démontré qu'on peut
travailler pour réduire les flux d'une
façon humaine c'est à dire en créant des
cannes mais gérée par les nations unies
en aidant année dans l'afrique à se
développer mais c'est des choses qui
demandent du temps c'est pas demain 1 et
aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit c'est les
migrants qui continuent à arriver moins
qu'avant mais nous devrons continuer à
arriver en grèce mais la grèce est pas
tomber pour autant dans une ssii leconte
de lisle continuer les îles à côté de la
turquie sont débordés et il n'ya pas
l'aide promise mais jamais jamais arrivé
ce qui se passe en europe aujourd'hui
c'est pas effectivement des mouvements
contre l'europe évidemment de
nationalisme s'ils gagnent finira par
détruire l'europe ça c'est une évidence
mais ils n'ont pas gagné en faisant
campagne contre l'europe par exemple le
mouvement 5 étoiles ils ont abandonné
leur idée de référendum sur l'euro et
ils ont fait une campagne sur
effectivement le travail l'emploi
l'extrême droite sur l'identité sur le
rejet de des étrangers c'est à dire que
l'extrême droite partout en europe a vu
que la sortie de l'europe
l'exemple du brésil et la haine ne
fonctionnait pas et donc ils ont
abandonné sa ils reviennent sur leur
coeur de métier qui est la xénophobie ou
des promesses
effectivement démagogique voilà ce que
je ne pars pas de parti populiste moi
personnellement je parle de partie
démagogique parce que j'estime que le
parti démocrate représente ou que syriza
représente le peuple dira autant que ces
gens de ces néo nazis ou donc pour
arrêter par les pattes de partis
populistes ou tous les partis tous les
élus représentent le peuple nous parlons
de partie démagogique c'est-à-dire
qu'ils promettent n'importe quoi en
sachant qu'ils n'auront pas les moyens
de tenir leurs promesses sur cette crise
est ce que c'est une crise de plus qu'a
connu l'italie où elle souhaite que la
laisse sérieuse elle menace vraiment
l'europe et les crises je ne pense pas
que ça menace l'europe
sa menace l'italie parce que l'italie
comme vous savez à une grosse dette et
est donc le robert excite version
italienne envisageable si tu es hier on
voit très bien que le break
c'est la gérer même pour un pays qui
était en dehors de tout comme la grande
bretagne
pour nous ce serait impossible mais
personne ne veut en réalité les italiens
ont dit clairement veut l'euro est
heureux a dit monique on préférera la
lie non je crois que ce sera très grave
surtout parce qu'on risque d'augmenter
ultérieurement la dette est de se
trouver dans une situation comme celle
grecque
mais l'italie n'est pas la grèce est
trop grande et en plus c'est vraiment
dommage parce qu'on était en train de
reprendre un excédent commercial qui est
le deuxième en europe et en pourcentage
est supérieur à celui allemand donc
notre économie est en train de se
reprendre
ma crainte c'est qu'elle elle retombe à
cause d'une augmentation de la dette qui
devient non tenables et qui nous met
dans la situation grecque
c'est là le vrai danger c'est pas
l'heure juste europe la prochaine
l'année prochaine on fera la campagne
sur l'europe et je craque de nouveau les
résultats vont changer justement la
grèce avoue me fait une parfaite
transition reste dans le sud de l'europe
donc direction la grèce après huit ans
d'austérité la grèce entre voit la
sortie de crise le pays a accepté de
privatiser ses ports ses autoroutes ses
aéroports à son énergie en échange de
l'argent des créanciers qui en a le
moins profité le reportage au port du
pirée qui appartient dorénavant au
groupe chinois cosco le reportage sur
place de françoise rey
[Musique]
oh
au petit matin le port du pirée se
réveille tranquillement mais à quelques
kilomètres l'activité est intense
et depuis l'arrivée d'une entreprise
chinoise il ya dix ans elle n'en finit
pas de grandir
cinq fois plus de containers passe dans
les pinces des immenses grues du port
pendant qu on augmentait la capacité du
quai numéro deux ont lancé la
construction d'un troisième quai et on
continue sa construction à la fin on
aura presque doubler les capacités du
port à la mi-2010 en 2016 l'entreprise
chinoise cosco a pris le contrôle du
port 67 % de la société à terme pour un
investissement promis de 700 millions
d'euros dans les cinq ans une aubaine
pour la grèce selon cosco je pense que
l'état grec et gagnants ont créé plus de
1600 nouvelles opportunités de travail
new évidemment on paie beaucoup de taxes
au gouvernement
nous permettons aussi à l'industrie de
croître
donc il y à un bénéfice mutuel dans ce
contrat
au sein de la structure propriétaire du
port autrefois majoritairement public
le discours ne dévie pas de la ligne
officielle de cosco nous pensons que
c'est une situation gagnant gagnant
le port du pirée a profité de gros
investissements
l'état grec n'aurait pas pu le faire
seul essai très favorable pour
l'économie locale et nationale
en plus de l'argent gagné en vendant ses
parts à causse qu il y a les
investissements déjà effectués et ceux
qui vont encore venir bac c'est un
investissement gagnant gagnant pas pour
tout le monde sous la pression de ses
créanciers la grèce a réduit le salaire
minimum déréguler le droit du travail et
baisser le pouvoir des syndicats et sur
le port cela s'est senti très vite
minimes à nos salaires ont baissé de 35%
ya plus d'horaires le patron peut
appeler pour travailler quand il veut en
ce moment dans le port nous sommes mille
employés avec 800 horaires différents
ils t'appellent quand il a besoin de toi
ça c'est la nouveauté que cosco applique
sur la totalité du port moment il ya une
croissance au pirée mais c'est à cause
qu seulement que ça profite pas à nous
ni à nos familles en grèce tout ou
presque est à vendre
il y a même un catalogue en ligne le
gestionnaire de gaz une autoroute
la compagnie de télécoms panayotis la
phase à nice est l'un des fondateurs de
syriza le parti de gauche anti austérité
actuellement au pouvoir ancien ministre
du gouvernement de sipera ce il a quitté
son poste lorsque le premier ministre
grec a accepté de poursuivre la vague de
privatisations sous la pression des
créanciers des privatisations
n'obéissent à aucune logique économique
quand on parle avec ces gens qui ordonne
les privatisations
on leur demande ce que la grèce et le
peuple gagne dans tout ça la réponse
c'est rien rien ne sert l'intérêt public
y en ait pas qui dément chercher faire à
partager
avec l'argent généré par les ventes au
secteur privé ils disent qu'ils vont
faire baisser la dette publique
aujourd'hui la grèce est une colonie de
dette qui doit tout accepter et se
laisser dépasser en tant que pays
souverain pour que la dette soit
remboursée sacrifices inévitables pour
certains pillages pour d'autres les
privatisations ont été la condition non
négociable pour que la grèce reçoive un
troisième plan daide de la troïka et
éviter la banqueroute
la gestion publique n'est pas efficace
et beaucoup de biens restent inexploités
le secteur public ne voulez pas investir
mais le problème des privatisations
surtout au début
c'est que vous ne pouvez pas négocier
une vente équitable
quand vous êtes en situation difficile
red one lieu aréna des faits qu'on sait
tous combien ces ventes ont rapporté à
la grèce il n'existe aujourd'hui aucun
chiffre officiel
tout juste les citoyens saft il que
l'ancien aéroport d'athènes a rapporté
un peu moins d'un milliard d'euros un
prix au mètre carré largement inférieur
au marché
sté losc ou love you est ce que la grèce
se retrouve financièrement avec ses ces
privatisations à qui profite cette
privatisation écouter mais plutôt aux
acheteurs qui est l'agressé évidemment
si on impose un pays d vendre les bijoux
de la famille un pays qui est en crise
et qui est qui qui n'a déjà témoigné à
se financer
alors ça va aboutir à une braderie c'est
ça qu'on a qu'on a vu qu'ils adressent à
ce moment là et les gouvernements tous
les gouvernements non seulement le
gouvernement de syrie ont été obligés de
les faire et c'est pas seulement les cas
de kochko au rapid chirurgie le cadet
des quatorze aéroports qui ont été
achetés par un consortium avec fera
porte une à deux reprises à limogne à la
tête
on a sélectionné les les airs pour le
profitable et par les échos pierre un
problème d'abord les la proposition
collègues étaient divisés en deux
groupes avec des bonnets des aéroports
bénéficiaire est aussi déficitaire mais
après on est dans notre galerie non il
faut vendre les quatorze aéroports
profitable non on a bâti tout et après
il ya d autres concessions à ses côtés
le contrat parce que là l'état grec
quand même va subventionner tous les
travaux
s'il ya un problème paraissait problème
assure logique l'état grec va
subventionner les travaux
supplémentaires
c'est aussi qu'ils se donnent encore
plus ou moins coloniale oui c'est
d'espresso il ya trois ans sur ce
plateau se demander si la grèce elle
allait sortir de ré de dubout le tunnel
la paf on nous dit qu'elle sort quand
même du tunnel mais qu'est ce qui s'est
passé alors je pense que la grèce a fait
beaucoup de sacrifices mais
malheureusement dans ce cas là il était
obligé parce que la date et
responsabilités non pas d'une mais des
gouvernements précédents
je crois que dans le cas du pirée par
exemple le pire est devenu compétitif
par rapport à rotterdam en certains me
l'aurait jamais vu hambourg il n'aurait
jamais pu le faire tout seul
la grèce est une plateforme naturelle
pour les changes avec l'est donc je
crois que dans ce cas ça a été une bonne
chose pourrait pour la grèce parce que
ça laisse à leur amène des
investissements après c'est clair il
faut redonner de la force syndicale pour
qu'ils résistent parce que le patron
chinois devra comme tous les patrons si
les syndicats de la force traiter avec
eux parce que il est obligé de
travailler là il peut pas amener le port
du pirée en chine c'est différent de par
exemple rendent une entreprise et dont
le lenovo va être transportée ailleurs
la le port est là et c'est un avantage
pour l'europe et pour la chine d'avoir
une plateforme efficace de pour les
commerces donc ça dépend des situations
je crois que aussi dans les aéroports un
des privés des allemands qui achètent
des aéroports en grèce ça veut dire
c'est triste pour l'italie ça veut dire
énormément de touristes allemands seront
transportés en grèce se dansait à
travers ses repas ses des
investissements qui amène des clients
agressent le bout du tunnel
mackay le ministre de l'eurozone des
finances de rejoindre qui disait que la
grèce coché toutes les cases
après neuf ans il est quand même temps
que la grèce sorte de la crise
alors si le gouvernement syriza ne fait
pas de bêtises comme le gouvernement de
la nouvelle démocratie en 2014 a fait où
ils sont crus à ce moment là que tout
est arrivé
il faut quand même se rappeler que la
crise a recommencé non pas à cause de
syriza on oublie un peu vite la cause de
samaras le patron nouvelle démocratie
calqué à 7 est terminée et il a replongé
le pays dans la crise alors je parle pas
de la gestion catastrophique des six
premiers mois et notamment du ministre
des finances de l'époque qui était le
fait de ne pas quitter sa moto plutôt
que de venir faire de la politique à
bruxelles mais il faut donc je crois
qu'il est temps de dire que tous les
pays qui ont connu une crise au bout de
trois ans sont sortis chypre portugal
l'irlande l'espagne de son plan bancaire
et c'est donc évidemment la grèce doit
en sortir
je me suis un petit peu de ce genre de
générer de deux photos instantanées
comprendre une situation la grèce
privatise wii est voir d'où elle est
partie voir que à partir des années 80
le parti socialiste espagnol gouverné
par papandreou père a lancé la grèce
dans un modèle qui était le modèle des
pays de l'est privatisation plupart dont
nationalisation de l'ensemble du secteur
économie la grèce c'était quoi c'était
un monstrueux au secteur économique
public qui ne fonctionnait pas avec des
micro entreprises très peu profitable à
tavers le petit hôtel la chambre chez
l'habitant
c'était ça la grèce et les grandes
fortunes partez à l'étranger pour
échapper effectivement à l'impôt et donc
ses grandes ces grandes entreprises
c'était quoi c'était un endroit où les
partis politiques placer leurs copains
c'était les copains et les coquins
il existe sur ce n'est pas ça la gestion
socialiste des socialistes après
nouvelle démocratie qui a trouvé
intérêts chacun placé ses amis c'était
un système clientéliste le port du pirée
tu étais un pur magnifique en entrant à
rendre compte ne fonctionnait pas les
aéroports on parle de la privatisation
de l'ancien aéroport d'athènes
attendez c'est en 2004 qu'il a fermé
personne n'a été fichu en cinq ans de
vendre eux s'étendre l'aéroport est en
bord de mer c'est un des endroits les
plus beaux d'athènes et ça n'a pas été
vendu
parlons du village olympique qui est en
ruine veut dire que ce truc aurait dû
être vendue et ben ça n'a pas été oriali
veille la capacité de l'état grec à
gérer l'économie parce que ce n'est pas
le rôle de l'état de gérer l'économie
donc le aujourd'hui il fallait en sortir
alors là je rejoins monsieur c'est qu'on
n'est pas sorti dans les meilleures
conditions
parce que quand il a fallu privatisée au
moment de la crise évidemment quand vous
êtes dos au mur ou privatisées dans les
pires conditions
mais il fallait sortir de ce système
alors à terme la grèce en bénéficiera
aura un secteur économique qui sera sans
doute plus plus actif plus attractif
mais c'est vrai que ils ont vendu les
bijoux de famille mais qui était dans un
sale état
c'était quand même les cuirs étaient
tordus et c'est dans les pires
conditions
voilà allez on passe à notre rubrique
donne fact checking à l'europe peut-elle
devenir encore plus démocratique
de l'avis de la commission et du
parlement européen oui un plus
précisément ils veulent rendre la
désignation du président de la
commission plus transparent
on y applique ont désormais directement
les lecteurs européens comment grâce au
système de style zen candidate à la va
vite si le candidat là le principe du
candidat en tête de liste cécile michaux
des couteaux regardant réagi juste après
[Musique]
comment sera désigné le prochain
président de la commission européenne
lors des élections de 2010 9
le débat est vif au sein de l'union
donald tusk président du conseil
européen assure que permettre à
l'électeur d'intervenir dans le choix du
président de la commission via un
procédé appelé speed jeune candidate ne
sera pas plus démocratique qui a aidé à
[Musique]
la commission et le parlement européens
eux veulent que ce système déjà appliqué
lors des élections de 2014
le souhaitent aussi en 2019 pour
comprendre l'origine de son désaccord
il faut se cacher sur les relations
entre les membres de ce trio
institutionnels commission et parlement
européen sont là entre autres pour
proposer voter et mettre en oeuvre la
législation européenne
les dirigeants des 28 états membres
forment le conseil européen qui est
surtout là pour donner une impulsion
dans la politique globale mais il a son
mot à dire dans certains domaines dont
celui de la désignation du président de
la commission
c'est le conseil qui choisit un candidat
comme président de la commission
et c'est au parlement d'approuver ou non
sa désignation est depuis le traité de
lisbonne en 2007 désignation doit tenir
compte des élections européennes
la commission et le parlement veulent
donc appliqué le speed jeune candidate
chaque parti politique choisi un
candidat tête de liste et le conseil de
choisir parmi ceux-ci voire même choisir
le candidat du parti majoritaire
les défenseurs du speed jeune candidate
espère ainsi favoriser la mobilisation
des citoyens aux élections européennes
les leaders européens eux craignent de
perdre un peu de leur pouvoir au sein de
l'union
mais aussi de voir les partis
eurosceptiques ou extrémiste remporter
les élections
leur argument pour défendre leur
légitimité les membres du parlement et
du conseil sont déjà directement élue
par les citoyens
mais grâce aux pics de la candidate
l'électeur peut directement intervenir
dans cette désignation
alors le système de speed jeunes
candidats tétine moins démocratique une
élection seulement influencé par les
dirigeants des états membres
c'est faux l'europe doit être plus
démocratique notamment au niveau de la
commission avait absolument le parlement
voudrait non seulement voter parce que
ça c'est notre pouvoir voter le
président de la commission si ce ne sera
pas celui qui a gagné les élections
aussi à travers une coalition il peut
gagner aussi à travers une coalition on
ne votera pas mais on voudrait voter
vraiment aussi les membres de la
commission et ne pas avoir un membre de
commission par enda membres chasser
c'est peu démocratique et peu efficace
justement jean quatremer vous avez
révélé pour libérer pour libération les
conditions controversées l'anomie scène
de la nuit nomination du secrétaire
général de la commission
c'est un alors c'est maintenant un
allemand martin c'est le meilleur un
braquage selon vous que c'est un
braquage parce que c'est un ami
personnel de jean claude juncker et ça
montre aussi je dirai tout le danger du
système des speeds un candidat tonnes
parce que au rythme où on est partis
actuellement comme le parti populaire
européen
les majorités en europe et va le rester
sans doute après les prochaines
élections ça veut dire que le président
de la commission sera de droite pour les
50 prochaines années et que on pourra
rien faire et qu'il pourra placer tous
ses hommes dans les institutions
on le voit au sein du parlement où vous
avez un secrétaire général allemand
claus velte qui place tous ces hommes du
ppe dans la machine administrative à la
commission c'est la même chose et la
commission et c'est à dire des
fonctionnaires non élus qui ont amené
noir en mémoire etc qui s'est passé à la
commission
c'est d'une gravité extrême
parce que là on passe notre temps à
donner des leçons aux grecs on va leur
expliquer comment ils font embaucher des
gens comment font embaucher les
fonctionnaires qu'il faut des procédures
claires et transparentes
là depuis trois semaines on pose des
questions à la commission sur les
conditions de nomination de martin c'est
le meilleur on n'a aucune réponse
une succession de mensonges moi j'ai
hâte ga que la légende la commission
retourne à athènes pour expliquer aux
grecs comment on fait une embauche non
contestable qu'est ce que vous reprochez
à cette nomination
c'est que sa mère et par le niveau il
n'avait pas le grade la procédure a été
violée il y avait qu'un seul candidat
etc etc je veux dire on se rend compte
en réalité que dès le départ il voulait
nommer son protégé martin senn mayer il
aurait pu nommer son cheval on le
faisait à une époque on faisait de son
cheval
un roi ou un vice roi aujourd'hui c'est
martine ses meilleurs ça me pose un
problème de démocratie de fonctionnement
de la commission
la fonctionnement des institutions
j'espère que le parlement va s'emparer
de cette affaire parce que ces étapes
sont d'accord ils essayent de s'en
emparer mais évidemment il ya le ppe
oui ce sera la mission a nécessairement
le premier parti mais la première
abolition
je vous rassure c'est au début de cette
émission pour plus d'informations je
renvoie aux téléspectateurs à votre blog
à ça s'appelle coulisses de bruxelles
sur internet cet exil a renoncé merci
merci d'être venus débattre avec nous
merci de nous avoir suivis bonne suite
des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires et la rtbf bail
[Musique]